♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," WE ARE GLAD YOU ARE
HERE, WE HAD A DIPLOMATIC
INCIDENT LAST MONTH THAT A LOT
OF AMERICANS DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED.
THE GOVERNMENT OF FRANCE,
SOMETHING THEY HAVEN'T DONE IT
HUNDREDS OF YEARS, THEY WERE
CALLED THEIR AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY ALSO ACCUSE THE
UNITED STATES OF BEHAVING IN A
MANNER WHICH IS UNACCEPTABLE
BETWEEN ALLIES AND PARTNERS.
IT WASN'T A CHEESE EMBARGO THAT
MADE THE FRENCH MAD, THEY WERE
ANGRY THAT BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
AGREED TO PROVIDE NUCLEAR
POWERED SUBMARINES TO AUSTRALIA.
FRANCE WANTED TO SELL ITS OWN
SUBMARINES IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION EFFECTIVELY
KILLED THAT DEAL.
IT HURT FRANCE AND THEY WERE MAD
ABOUT IT.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A PROBLEM WITH
FRANCE THIS PROFOUND SINCE, TO
BE SPECIFIC, 1798.
JOHN ADAMS WAS PRESIDENT OF DAN
AND THE INTERESTING THING IS HE
HAD NO IDEA WE HAD A PROBLEM
WITH FRANCE, IT TOOK MONTHS FOR
WORD TO REACH HIM IN WASHINGTON
THAT AMERICAN AND FRENCH
DIPLOMATS WERE FIGHTING WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
BY THE TIME ADAMS LEARNT ABOUT
THIS DIPLOMATIC DISPUTE WHICH
BECAME KNOWN AS THE XYZ AFFAIR,
IT WAS TOO LATE TO STOP IT.
WITH THAT IN MIND, JOHN KERRY
WAS ASKED WHAT HAPPENED HERE IN
HIS RESPONSE WAS SIMPLE.
LIKE JOHN ADAMS, JOE BIDEN HAD
NO IDEA THE FRENCH WERE UPSET.
UNLIKE JOHN ADAMS, OUR CURRENT
PRESIDENT HAD THE BENEFIT OF
CELL PHONES AND THE INTERNET.
JILL BIDEN DIDN'T KNOW BECAUSE
HE'S A MENTAL DECLINE, THERE ARE
A LOT OF THINGS HE DOESN'T KNOW
INCLUDING WHEN OUR ALLIES ARE
FURIOUS WITH US, STARTING WITH
WITHDRAWING THEIR AMBASSADOR'S.
HIM HE WAS ASKED TO EXPLAIN ALL
THIS, WHY DID THAT BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CUT FRANCE OUT OF
THE NUCLEAR SUBMARINE DEAL, HIS
RESPONSE WAS AMAZING.
HE SAID JOE BIDEN DID THIS
BECAUSE HE WAS COMPLETELY
UNAWARE THERE WAS A PROBLEM IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ASKED ME
ABOUT IT AND I TOLD HIM --
>> YOU TOLD JOE BIDEN --
>> HE ASKED ME, HE SAID WHAT'S
THE SITUATION AND I EXPLAINED
EXACTLY, HE HAD NOT BEEN AWARE
OF THAT.
HE HAD NOT BEEN AWARE OF WHAT
HAD TRANSPIRED.
>> Tucker: ONCE LESS TIME YOU
HEARD SOMEONE FROM THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT ADMITS THE PRESIDENT
WAS COMPLETELY CLUELESS?
HE HAD NOT BEEN AWARE OF WHAT
HAD TRANSPIRED.
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT SHOCKED BY
THAT, JOE BIDEN WAS VISIBLY
CONFUSED THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, HERE'S
ONE EXAMPLE.
>> NO MAN HAS A RIGHT TO RAISE A
HAND TO A WOMAN IN ANGER OTHER
THAN IN SELF-DEFENSE AND THAT
RARELY EVER IT OCCURS.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE CULTURE,
PERIOD.
AND KEEP PUNCHING AT IT AND
PUNCHING AT IT AND PUNCHING AT
ITS.
>> PLAYS THE RADIO, MAKE SURE
THE TELEVISION -- EXCUSE ME,
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE RECORD
PLAYER ON AT NIGHT.
>> WE CHOOSE SCIENCE OVER
FICTION, WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVER
FACTS.
>> Tucker: WE AREN'T TRYING TO
BE MEAN, AS WE SAID MANY TIMES
WE FEEL SORRY FOR JOE BIDEN, ALL
OF US HOPE TO LIVE TO THE AGE
WHERE WE FACE THOSE KINDS OF
PROBLEMS AND THE TRUTH IS VOTERS
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE GETTING WHEN
THEY VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS NOW HE IS
IN OFFICE, HIS HANDLERS ARE
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
PREVENT US FROM NOTICING HE'S
NOT REALLY IN CHARGE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE LATEST
EXAMPLE, THESE ARE PICTURES OF A
FAKE WHITE HOUSE SET THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS FOR SOME
REASON CONSTRUCTED ACROSS THE
STREET FROM THE ACTUAL
WHITE HOUSE, IN THE EISENHOWER
EXECUTIVE OFFICE BUILDING.
WHY GROWTH OF THE TROUBLE?
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE, STEPHEN MILLER
SPENT THE LAST FOUR YEARS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AS AN ADVISOR AND
HERE IS HIS EXPLANATION FOR IT
TWO THE REASON BIDEN USES THIS
BIZARRE VIRTUAL SET FOR
TELEVISED MEETINGS, NOT AN
ACTUAL ROOM LIKE THE EAST ROOM
FOR THE CABINET -- THE REASON HE
DOES THIS IS BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
HIM TO READ A SCRIPT DIRECTLY
FROM A FACE ON MONITOR AND
WITHOUT TELEPROMPTERS THAT CAN
BE SEEN ON CAMERA.
WE CAN'T VERIFY THAT IS TRUE BUT
IT CERTAINLY SOUNDS RIGHT.
JOE BIDEN CAN'T SPEAK FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE BECAUSE HE'S NOT
SURE WHAT TO SAY SO WE HAVE TO
READ IT ALL.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO GLOAT OVER
IT BUT THE MUCH MORE IMPORTANT
QUESTION TO THE REST OF US IS IF
HE'S NOT RUNNING THE GOVERNMENT,
THEN WHO IS?
THAT'S THE REAL QUESTION.
CLEARLY THE FBI, THE DOJ, AND
THE MILITARY ARE ALREADY ACTING
INDEPENDENTLY OF THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THEY DON'T EVEN KEEP HIM AND
INFORMED OF INTERNATIONAL
INCIDENTS.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE IN SOME CASES
FREELANCING TO CRUSH ANYONE WHO
OPPOSES THEIR POWER.
MIKE FLYNN FOR EXAMPLE, HE WAS
BRIEFLY THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM THE
DESTRUCTION OF MIKE FLYNN,
REALLY, WAS THAT SURE, YOU CAN
ELECT DONALD TRUMP PRESIDENT BUT
DOES HE REALLY RUN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT?
IT TURNED OUT BARACK OBAMA WAS
STILL IN CHARGE EVEN THOUGH HE
WAS NO LONGER PRESIDENT.
OBAMA HAD HIS CRONIES CHARGE
MICHAEL FLYNN WITH A CRIME,
TALKING TO RUSSIA, AS THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR WHICH
IS NOT A CRIME BY ANY STRETCH
AND THEY WRECKED HIS LIFE FOR
DOING THAT.
TOOK YEARS FOR US TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT HAPPENED THERE, BUT NOW
IT'S OBVIOUS, WE SAT DOWN WITH A
LONG INTERVIEW WITH MIKE FLYNN,
COMING UP MONDAY.
HE TOLD US WHAT IS REALLY
OBVIOUS TO EVERYONE WATCHING IT,
UNELECTED GROUP WITHIN
WASHINGTON EFFECTIVELY RUNS THE
COUNTRY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
VOTERS, HERE IS HIS ASSESSMENT.
>> WE HAVE TWO SEPARATE
GOVERNMENTS, WE HAVE THE ONE
THAT GETS ELECTED AND GOES INTO
OFFICE AND YOU HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT INSIDE OF
WASHINGTON, D.C., THAT OPERATES
UNDER NO RULES, NO AUTHORITIES
OTHER THAN THEIR OWN OR WHO WAS
EVER IN CHARGE.
>> Tucker: SOUNDS LIKE THAT
GOVERNMENT WAS STILL CONTROLLED
BY BARACK OBAMA.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT TO A DEGREE
IS WHAT WE ARE OPERATING WITH
TODAY.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY, MIKE
FLYNN IS NOT SOME INTERNET
CELEBRITY OR CONSERVATIVE
ACTIVIST, HE WAS A THREE-STAR
GENERAL, THE HEAD OF AN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY, THE NUMBER
TWO GUY -- HE SPENT HIS ENTIRE
LIFE WORKING ON A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SUCCEEDING AT
THAT, HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT, HE IS A RELIABLE GUIDE TO
HOW THE GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY
WORKS.
OUR WHOLE CONVERSATION WITH MIKE
FLYNN IS ON TUCKER CARLSON AND
COMES OUT MONDAY ON FOX NATION.
IT'S NOT JUST MIKE FLYNN BEING
DESTROYED, EVERY IDEOLOGICAL
OPPONENT OF THE REGIME IS UNDER
ATTACK, PARENTS IN SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS SAYING UNAPPROVED
THINGS, YESTERDAY'S JOE BIDEN'S
SLACK -- USING THE PATRIOT ACT
TO HUNT DOWN AMERICAN PARENTS
WHO ARE UPSET ABOUT WHAT THEIR
KIDS ARE LEARNING, WATCH THIS.
>> WITH THE ADMINISTRATION BE
OKAY WITH THE FBI USING THE
PATRIOT ACT TO SURVEILLED THESE
PARENTS?
>> I DON'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION, I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THIS GOVERNMENT, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS PUT OUT A
LETTER, THEY WILL TAKE ACTIONS
THEY TAKE AND I WOULD POINT YOU
TO THEM FOR MORE INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: THIS IS THE
SPOKESMAN FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SAYING THEY
ARE GOING TO TAKE ACTIONS THEY
ARE GOING TO TAKE LIKE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONTROL OVER THIS.
SHE MAY BE ONTO SOMETHING THERE.
IT DOES INCREASINGLY SEEM LIKE
THE NATIONAL SECURITY STATE RUNS
EVERYTHING.
REMEMBER THE DOJ RECENTLY
DISPATCHED ITS ANTITERRORISM
NATIONAL SECURITY DIVISION TO
INVESTIGATE ORDINARY PARENTS
CALLING THEM DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS, THE DOJ IS ALSO
DEVELOPING TRAINING SESSIONS TO
TELL SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS THAT
FREE SPEECH IS ACTUALLY VIO